live and direct from Hollywood The
Hunger Squad today we have a very
special episode of peaceful hunger squad
we will be going to eat signature dishes
from each other's hometown I'm from the
Midwest
now me being from Virginia which is the
East Coast aka I guess the South they're
gonna have a lot to live up to and being
from San Diego California pretty sure I
got this one in the bag so I think we
need to make a little bit of a
competition out of it
wait no this is not a contest yes this
is a contest this is a bonding
experience for the feast mode hunger
squad it's a contest no Freddie it's not
a contest
yeah I see up here Steven Ohio ain't got
nothing on me you're worried you're
gonna lose aren't you shut up
so we're on our way to Ricky's fish
tacos in East Hollywood it's a truck we
get to sit outside enjoy this beautiful
Southern California day
doesn't he have like a million taco
trucks no he's got one because he's a
man of quality I respect that he's a
monogamist
are you a one-man kind of girl I am a
one-man kind of girl how are you this is
Ricky of Ricky's fish tacos where did
you learn how to make fish tacos I've
been eating them since I was a little
kid you know mom from Ensenada they know
how to make fish necklaces we are going
to eat a lot of your fish tacos right
okay thank you I literally ate fish
tacos every single day after baseball
practice with my dad with eating taco
I will say I am the most excited about
this mayo sauce oh I don't even know if
you want this you want this I guess I do
now Cheers
well your mm Wow Ricky's gets extra
points because we put a surfboard in his
logo he gets two points for that
Ricky also gets two points for that yeah
Brittney gets five points for just
keeping it that's the thing about tacos
it's really all about the meat look at
that ratio looks good Ricky three points
for having quality tortillas three
points for the crunch your love crunch
I love crimes like you love ratios all
these sauces are on point plus one per
sauce boom boom boom boom solid four
points with the atmosphere even the
patrons are just super diverse everyone
who's here at this Chuck on their lunch
break they look like they come from like
all walks of life three points to the
three specks of food that are left on
Colin's mustache right now the flavor
savor no I hope you guys got a good fish
taco experience enjoyed it yep it was
okay I'm trying to save room for the
next spot we're gonna have some amazing
vbq we're heading to my spot it's known
for its like texas-style barbecue and
I'm not from Texas I'm from Virginia but
I would say that's the closest you can
get to like Virginia barbecue the sweet
to savory ratio in the barbecue sauce
must be correct I love me some ratios
already you know the key to my heart
so we're here at my spot AKA blood cells
this is sad how you guys doing basically
everything on this menu I'm upset with I
mean I can just send you guys out what I
think it's best to if you want to just
go with that
Wow if this doesn't make your mouth
water water than y'all are just dead
people inside okay here the South coming
out of you right now Freddy presentation
they get fired presentation points yes
what everything oh oh goodness see that
when you pick it up
that's a +10 real deal right here
major flavor points here we're gonna
five fat flavor three points for the
tender three three again just start
dishing out points alright randomly why
there is no skin we're just giving
points like crazy beautiful for how
buttery that is let's do Cheers
ooh that's a negative one right there
we're talking about it's not it's bold
it's your fault you guys out here tried
to duck point that you get nervous I'll
give I'll give another three points for
that mac and cheese it's still some
solid Mac use everything melts in your
mouth I maybe could eat this a pickle
crunch on please we gotta try that spicy
things
hmm
and there truly is an art to just like
making good comforts and I think this
place nails plus 17 points okay there's
gonna be some order no oh how am I gonna
stay awake in the bar Oh
where we going alright again this is not
a chili I've never heard about
Cincinnati chili until I met this one
over here what it's world-famous I think
it's Cincinnati famous no we are on the
way to my spot the closer things at home
focusing lens by chili John's over in
Cincinnati we have these things got
three ways and it's not what you're
thinking
they are chili cheese and noodles we are
here with Anthony what is your signature
dish here beef and beans are california
stink beat this place reminds me know
much of the Midwest I'm gonna give him
five points just for decor I'm digging
the vibe in here two points to the
lobster bit see how fast this guy's Ohio
likes our food fast
all right the fact that I came out in
ten seconds ten points come on yeah now
do you guys have she to throw on there
have buckets of cheese whoa
so how much do you should I put on here
Stephen there is so much cheese this
gets five points just off the beans oh
then we got onions onions go on there
too right one tiny plus five points for
all the variations to mix and match I
gotta say if spaghetti was like this all
the time I probably eat it well this is
like a great quaint date
that's a key to my spot what do you
think I'm doing right now Freddie oh man
I'm getting meat sweats point system
wise I think we know who won I feel like
I know you guys better now it's better
as a bonding experience yeah what are
you doing next time guys peace peace
wonders what signing out
comment below what we eat next let's do
it yes what do you think